so have you ever had the idea of
packaging what you know into an online
course that doesn't just make money but
also changes lives what is the
opportunity in the e-learning industry
right now it's over a billion dollars a
day in sales people don't buy your
course they buy the transformation you
promise through your course
we're going to be learning from one of
my friends an expert on online courses
Marisa Murgatroyd Marisa welcome thank
you thank you super stoked for
everything we're going to talk about
today I'm so grateful that you're on the
podcast you know we met up in person in
Miami a while back have been watching
what you do for a long time you have a
ton of respect and Authority kind of in
this industry just briefly tell people
um about your story of how you got to
where you are today with your expertise
and how you help people well believe it
or not I was a documentary filmmaker and
I was making about a thousand bucks a
week and I would only make money when I
showed up to work and worked on films
and after you know five six seven years
of doing that I just started to question
not just what I was doing in terms of my
lifestyle in terms of how much money I
was making but also the average
documentary was only seen by a thousand
people back then and it's really hard to
you know get something seen and so I
felt like I was working really hard and
I wasn't really making an impact and I
wasn't seeing the a kind of Financial
and lifestyle Freedom that I wanted and
I just started to ask myself you know
what else could I do and to be honest I
came up kind of blank I was like uh you
know I know how to make things look good
I know how to make things sound good I
know how to tell a good story but who in
the world is going to pay me for that
and the really interesting thing is that
I just didn't know what I didn't know
because I didn't realize that those
three things making things look good and
sound good and telling good stories well
it kept me broke as an artist in a
completely other dimension it was the
basis of all business and marketing and
I had actually been sitting on a million
dollar skill set that I thought wasn't
valued well I've been told it wasn't
valuable my entire life and then here I
could help people solve really big
problems with that skill set and make a
lot more money and make a lot more
impact and so what happened is I
gradually started asking myself well you
know where can I even start to use these
skills and I thought you know the
intersection of the internet and
entrepreneurship and I just remember
starting to create service offerings and
then ultimately courses and it just
gradually snowballed it wasn't easy I
made a lot of mistakes I had some failed
products and things like that but
eventually I was able to turn that
million dollar skill set into millions
of dollars and I think everyone has the
million dollar skill set they don't have
the other set of million dollar skills
you need to turn it into that really
kind of profitable and impactful set of
skills it's amazing and what are some of
the opportunities and what's called the
e-learning industry or maybe what are
some of the other terms for it because
if someone clicked on this video this
episode of the audio podcast they're
probably already familiar with online
courses they've heard stories they've
heard the opportunity maybe they're
halfway through a course maybe one is
sitting on their hard drive or one is
sitting on the internet already but just
is not selling let's zoom out just for a
second before we get very tactical what
is the growth of this industry what is
the opportunity that is available for
listeners yeah well it's over a billion
dollars a day in sales like people are
investing more than a billion dollars a
day around the world and going online to
learn how to do things or solve problems
or get results they can't on their own
and this e-learning or online education
industry it incorporates things like
home study courses digital products
online courses some of which are cohort
based you might have a group going
together at the same time group coaching
programs you know information based
subscriptions or memberships there's
quite a lot of different kinds of things
that fall under this whole online
education
um you know umbrella and some of which
you can see you know universities
getting in on the action big
corporations who need to onboard or
upskill or reskill their employees and
then of course all the people who just
go online to learn for their own
benefits yeah that's a a billion dollars
a day is staggering and you start
thinking about just getting a small
piece of that would be absolutely
life-changing for someone that's going
into this or a business owner that's
maybe wanting to Pivot and start not
just doing the thing but now teaching
the thing and packaging what they know
but why do a lot of courses fail to sell
yeah I think one of the big challenges
people have is coming up with the right
topic the right idea and the reason
being is people think that people buy
courses to learn right because they're
curious about a topic because that's how
we grew up in school you study history
and you study math and you study English
but when you're looking at this kind of
online course industry outside of the
main kind of educational institutions
people don't usually buy just because
they're curious they buy because they
want to do something or become something
or feel something that they can't do or
become or feel on their own so people
actually buy courses because they want a
specific result they want to solve a
problem they they want to realize
something in their lives it could be
simple like learning how to bake really
good sour bread you know sourdough bread
or it could be something like developing
active listening skill set or it could
be how do you get a raise or a promotion
in the workforce or how do you have a
better relationship with your life
partner even how do you find a life
partner so there's almost anything you
can go online to learn of course in your
field how do you create a YouTube video
how do you create a following there's so
many things that you can teach people
how to do but the main thing is people
want an outcome they want a result
they're not just learning because
they're curious about a topic brilliant
and you also have a resource that I want
to make sure people can get a hold of
and so at bestcourcetopics.com if you
like you said figuring out the right
course itself the right topic and you
actually put together the 20 most
profitable online course Mega niches to
help people find the right idea and so
I'll mention this a little bit later but
I want to let people know that that's in
the show notes that's in the description
and or you can just go to
bestcourcetopics.com and that's a free
gift that you put together for um people
what I love about what you're doing is
you've kind of coined this this phrase
of not just making an online course but
making it an actual experience why do a
lot of courses fail to actually get
results for students 100 well the
shocking number number is actually that
97 of people who buy a traditional
online course what most people are
creating don't actually complete the
course and get the results that are
promised because if you've ever tried to
do something alone at home online with
no accountability and no support you
know you probably have just sort of
flaked out or gotten distracted and
stopped Midstream even in the middle of
a YouTube video how many of them do you
actually complete right because
information is everywhere it's on you
can kind of type anything into Google or
into YouTube and just get a huge amount
of free content but content and
information isn't actually what makes
people change their lives which is why
I'm not at all worried about artificial
intelligence Ai and chat GPT and all
this AI generated content that's coming
out because experience products are a
new kind of online course or program
that I've really innovated that stack
these 10 core experiences and I've got
them right here that stack 10 core
experiences into your course that create
an almost addictive you know learning
experience and that's a good thing
because we're addicted to our phones
we're addicted to social media and we
can use the same tactics that a lot of
the Silicon Valley companies know but in
our course and we can do it in a really
simple way so people get hooked on
transforming their lives through your
course so what I believe is that now the
barrier to entry is so much lower with
AI and AI makes an incredible you know
brainstorming partner and support in
creating content faster but when you can
combine that ease and accessibility with
this experiential approach where people
are leaning in to what it is that you're
teaching or delivering and they actually
start taking action and changing their
lives and getting their results and
enjoying the experience and feeling
things along the way versus just getting
bombarded with content then you've kind
of got the key to really succeed in this
particular environment one of the
objections people might feel though they
think okay if I have the right topic and
if I also you know follow you learn your
tips to even make the course great what
if I don't have a big following like
where would I actually get customers now
I've created this thing and maybe I only
have a few YouTube subscribers maybe I'm
just getting started maybe I'm in I'm on
Instagram is it possible to make money
with courses with a small following and
do you have any examples of stories or
students
so I actually teach what I call an earn
while you learn approach so if you're
just getting started I think trying to
create this massive online course with
thousands of people each paying you 50
bucks or 100 bucks it's kind of counter
productive because it takes you know is
a lot more to earn say a hundred
thousand dollars with people paying you
a hundred dollars then it does turn a
hundred thousand dollars with people
paying you a thousand or even ten
thousand dollars so when you create
courses in this experiential way
designed to get people a specific result
you can actually create programs that
you sell to one person at a time or you
sell to just a small group and when you
test your idea that way you just start
getting paid as you develop your
reputation as you develop your results
your case studies and as you develop
your following and when you start
getting paid by you know creating more
higher ticket programs like more
expensive programs to few or people then
you can invest in say growing your
audience so when you do it that way
you're actually able to get started
before you have any following at all
because the truth is it all comes down
to creating something that one person
will give you money for and once one
person gives you money for it then
deliver an incredible experience and
have more people give you money for that
and then once you've tested the
viability of that model then you can
start to leverage and scale beyond that
so I've got this little diagram here
that Revenue like how much you're making
equals volume times price right so many
people I'm doing this backwards because
that's the camera so many people think
that you know the only way to create a
course is to have a lot of people paying
you a little bit of money but you can
actually store this is really actually
harder than you'd expect I need to look
at it you're gonna try it for us but
yeah just try to point to the right
direction yeah you want to have if you
start with just a few people paying you
a lot of money and then you go like
one-on-one one person at a time then you
gradually increase to say a few people
paying you you know a little bit less
money then you're testing the model
along the way you're gaining resources
you're gaining reputation you're gaining
credibility and then pretty soon you can
start to create that course with a
thousand people in it the problem is
when people try to start with the course
with a thousand people in it does that
make sense ramp up there pretty quickly
you just got to kind of follow the right
approach to test the viability of that
model first so smart and I know that you
also kind of help people launch kind of
like beta groups or like this whole idea
of testing the product you know when we
launched video ranking Academy our main
online course
um today it's been re-shot four times I
want to say we're 13
000 or 15 000 students or something like
that's just wild but when it first
started it was one at a time via
Facebook Messenger via Zoom calls and
one-on-one Co coaching of the idea of
the course and actually for free at
first because I wanted to get some video
testimonials and even see if it worked I
added some theories and to see okay can
I coach somebody for ranking videos
getting some better results on their
YouTube channel and so I love and and
you're that was me fumbling my way
through things I wish I at that time had
you know your Frameworks and all of that
kind of stuff but what it taught me was
that you can work your way into this
thing one step at a time and that
there's different levels and had I also
started higher tickets super smart and
wise and then eventually creating an at
scale program again I want to make sure
separate to your gift there's also a
challenge that you have available so
you're probably wondering what the 10
core experiences are and and some
different things like that and so I want
to encourage you this won't be available
forever but you do have a challenge if
you're listening to this podcast within
maybe a couple weeks of when it comes
out that is live and in depth talk a
little bit about that and we'll make
sure to just put a link in the show
notes to that but what are you going to
be teaching on that yeah it's the five
Day craft your course idea Challenge and
it took me about 12 years to distill the
process around finding the right topic
the right the right idea into just five
simple steps that'll take you 15 to 30
minutes a day for five days it's
completely free one time a year which
means I think it's free in just a few
days after this is coming out so you can
jump in and we've had 27 000 people go
through this challenge to find their
idea and it really simplifies the
process and gives you parameters to know
am I just crazy thinking this is going
to work to actually oh okay I know this
is gonna work right and so that's what
we're gonna do and we'd love for you to
join us and it's also designed as an
experience product meaning you're going
to get to see all of these experiences
that I'm talking about and how it
inspires you to get super motivated and
do things that you might have kind of
started to do in the past but then
stopped or got bored or got distracted
you'll see how all of these experiences
work on you to get you hyper excited and
Hyper motivated and doing things that
you haven't been able to do before
beautiful so depending on when you're
listening to this definitely take
advantage of all these resources and
they'll be listed out in the show notes
but it makes me wonder even if we lock
in what our course is going to be about
answer this objection of what if
somebody has already created a course on
my topic yeah well the reason why this
whole experience formula is so important
is that you can create a course and get
a result that a perhaps other people
don't in a way that's more enjoyable for
somebody else so it's not just about the
information it's really about the
transformation and how you deliver that
transformation is going to be specific
to your personality to your life
experience to your particular strengths
to your delivery style and all of those
things and the truth is that not every
person resonates with every potential
teacher I mean there are teachers out
there I'm like no way would I I ever try
to learn from that particular person so
it's actually a good thing if someone
else is out there teaching it because it
means that they're getting paid for that
and it means that there's a market for
that particular thing and if you can see
the whole in what they're doing either
they're overlooking something important
or you can do it differently or you can
just do it in a way that appeals to a
different you know demographic or you
can deliver the same thing but to a
different audience you know those are
all ways to differentiate yourself and
get in on the action and I will say that
there's something like five billion
people on the internet and they don't
all know about the one person that you
might be comparing yourself to so when
you start to build your own following
and you have your own circle of
influence that you develop and even if
you're just getting started you have a
circle of influence you have people that
you know you have people you've met you
have people you've interacted with over
the course of your life you can start
there and then gain momentum from that
point it's brilliant and I um want to
shout out now some of our think media
podcast listeners that took action and
responded to a community tab question
and so I know we have so many people
that listen on audio but there is some
special action that happens on the
YouTube channel and I ask people if
they've ever thought about creating a
paid online course and what questions
they have weezido simples I really
slaughtered this name but uh it's a most
thumbed up question said you know the
hardest part is actually selling the
product like eventually we got to sell
it and communicate why people really
need it just address a little bit of
course you go deeper in your content I
think a lot of people eventually they're
like I want to teach I want to serve I
want to make a difference in people's
lives I want to package what I know I
want to educate but I don't want to sell
like what do you mean you know sales and
so what what is maybe some mindset tips
about learning the skill or just
embracing the idea that yeah you're
gonna have to promote and sell this
thing yeah well first of all
um I describe sales and marketing as the
process of helping people develop the
attitudes beliefs and conditions they
need to say yes not just to you but to
themselves does that make sense so I
think a lot of people think of marketing
and sales as this kind of like sleazy
manipulative thing but everything that
we are doing here right now in this
interview it's marketing and sales
because it's answering questions it's
providing value it's building connection
and relationship and so when you can see
that a lot of times you have more reach
in Marketing sales than you will ever
have in terms of people buying from you
so I've touched you know probably
millions of people through my marketing
and sales process and even though a
small fraction like maybe one percent of
those millions of people have bought
from me that's enough to have a
significant business and I think people
forget that you know you're not about
trying to get everybody to buy from you
you're trying to get your people to buy
from you and one of the tips that I've
got for you right now that's going to be
actionable is that one of the biggest
reasons that people struggle to get
people to buy is they're not super clear
about the promise of their course or
their program in terms of exactly what
is that courser program going to allow
someone to do or be or become or feel
and so I've got a template I call my
mission possible template and it allows
you to phrase the promise of your course
in a way that gets people excited so the
template goes like this your mission
should you choose to accept it is blank
all right so the mission of my
experience product master class is your
mission should you choose to accept it
is to design launch and profit from an
experienced product in 12 weeks or less
so you can get off the marketing
treadmill make more sales and serve more
people right so it's so clear and
specific you know exactly what you're
going to do you know exactly how long
it's going to take and I've had helped
you know thousands of students come up
with missions for their products even
ones where they felt like they couldn't
come up with a mission you know and one
of my students I'm going to try to find
the exact language because it was so
good was actually a shaman and he was
like Marissa I can't make a promise I
can't promise instant Enlightenment you
know because the actual transformation
he thought took 17 years to complete
right it took 17 years to you know
become a knowledge Keeper in the
shamanic tradition I'm like you know
that's really hard to get someone to you
know want to commit to a 17-year journey
because people need a little more
instant gratification right and so he
kind of told me what we do and you know
I asked him well helmet is it possible
for someone to just feel any of this
stuff even if it's just for a fraction
of a second like they're not gaining
Mastery but could they feel some of
these things you're talking about like
unconditional love for a fraction of a
second he says yeah absolutely so we
came up with this your mission should
you choose to accept it is to receive
through the six-week shamanic and
initiation the four essential energies
and gifts that every human needs to feel
whole loved and on path the gift of
knowing your truth the gift of
connecting to your life energy the gift
of a quiet mind and the gift of opening
to the infinite now once he had this he
emailed 18 people and he got something
like 21 sales so he got he got people
were so excited about it because he had
made this big abstract topic so specific
so he just emailed 18 people and said
I've got the six week shamanic
initiation coming up here's what it's
going to allow you to do they all said
yes and three of them referred friends
so he had 120 conversion rate just like
that and I think he made eleven thousand
dollars and it was his very first
program his very first attempt and he
had a topic that he didn't think he
could translate into a specific promise
so a lot of times the reason why it's
hard to sell a program is people don't
really know what it is that you're
actually selling because people don't
buy your course they buy the
transformation you promise through your
course and simply having that clear
specific transformation and by the way
we have like AI generators to create
your mission possible statement too if
it's not your strength so when we teach
that inside of the challenge as well so
simply getting that right I've had
people just instantly start to make
sales by simply sharing this one piece
of messaging because it was so clear
people knew exactly what winning looked
like so I always say you want this to be
so clear and specific you could
photograph people reaching the finish
line of the program and when you've got
that it makes a really big difference so
a lot of times when something's hard to
sell it's actually just because you're
not promising something specific enough
or the transformation isn't clear enough
so simply doing that one thing will
actually make people really want what
you have to offer wow Clarity is hard
but it's so powerful and I love that
you've created Frameworks to lead us to
that Clarity Julian asks about
platforms I'm sure a lot of listeners go
to the technical I wonder if you have
any favorites or when you point to
people to things like circle is a trend
cohorts are a trend I think we actually
recently did something in circle we've
done something in Mighty networks
there's kajabi click funnels any
thoughts about the relevance of how
important it is to pick the right
platform and and tips when it comes to
that I always advise people to be
careful allowing kind of to put the cart
before the horse first understanding and
creating your program because there's so
many options and they're all going to do
the job we actually did create our own
platform about five years ago no not
five maybe three or four years ago
called experienceify that has all of
these um gamification triggers and it's
the world's first fully gamified
learning management system and we have a
lot of social media influencers coming
onto that platform people like Jay
Shetty like Dan Bilzerian I mean people
who've got big followings because it
brings almost this social media
component into an online line course
where people can kind of Click buttons
they can interact they can engage so
experienceify is the platform I
recommend I mean I did happen to build
it but we got it's legit a lot of people
are using that platform because it gets
people engaged in like 10 to 30 times
more likely to complete so when you add
all of this gamification to you know the
right idea and the right promise and the
right program kind of design it really
supercharges everything and what you'll
find is that when people get that result
they're way more likely to buy from you
and they're way more likely to refer
people to you and your business starts
to grow actually almost organically
because you're actually doing what other
people don't do you're creating an
extraordinary experience that gets
people results you're adding so much
value and I'm excited to get to a few
more of these questions that have come
from our community but I do want to
remind everyone that
bestcourcetopics.com is a must go go to
URL where you can get the 20 most
profitable online course Mega niches to
find the right course idea for you and
so that is in the show notes or go to
bestcourcetopics.com you of course can
also go to the show notes depending on
if you caught this around the time it
was released to be a part of the once a
year free challenge that Marisa is
leading and so hit that up and if
there's still time to jump into that you
can get into that for free and it's
going to be so much more thorough than
we can be in the remaining few minutes
here but be Queen asks length of a
course for beginners what's kind of the
spectrum of do I have to make a 50 hour
course a 500 hour course or could it be
relatively short and she did include in
the question that is a beginner course
well this is the really beautiful thing
about the way that I teach online
courses that's really different from
every everybody else is first of all
it's not about the information like I
said information alone people can get it
for free all over the Internet they
don't expect to pay for it more content
is not better people want the shortcut
so when you've defined your mission
statement then all you need to do is to
deliver the minimum amount of content
necessary to get someone that particular
result so we think we have to just add
everything we know or anything someone
could possibly know but a lot of times
that gets in the result of just the
fastest you know it gets in the way of
the fastest path to the actual promise
or to the actual result and one of the
other things that I recommend doing the
first time is actually delivering the
program live so so many people think
they need to use all this Tech and
pre-record all the videos and everything
else but I actually recommend just start
small with the small group of people
whether you deliver live to one person
or six people or 20 people and just go
live say whether it's on Zoom or
whatever it happens to be because you'll
get that feedback in the chat from the
people and that's going to allow you to
fine tune your program before you go and
do all that big production and record
and edit and all that takes a lot of
time and a lot of expense and the truth
is you're you're probably gonna have to
redo it after the first time you go
through it anyway because you'll learn
all the questions people have the things
that weren't clear what they want versus
what you thought that they needed
another question uh worship TV 7 asked
how do I price it and uh Tia asked
how many hours at what cost is
reasonable so it sounds like you've
already kind of said that's kind of the
wrong question because it's not people
don't just want more content they want a
transformation so what's kind of your
thought for coming up with a the right
pricing for an online course well a lot
of it is based on the value of the
transformation and also it's based on
how you get people there so I have uh
programs that are up to fifty thousand
dollars right and I have programs that
are seven dollars so it's really looking
at what is the depth and value of the
transformation you know of course part
of it's the length of the program it's
the amount of support that you add too
so there's so many different forms of
online courses and a lot of time and
it's the offer that you make so in an
offer you might have some kind of review
component some kind of done for you
components I'm kind of done with you
component access to tools and it doesn't
even have to be your tools it could be a
partnership with somebody else so
there's so many ways to add value to an
offer that's going to help people get
that result more predictably and
reliably or more quickly so I think a
lot of people look at a course from a
limited frame of just a certain number
of videos right that you can charge like
a hundred bucks for and when you
understand that there's so many ways to
develop an experience product and you
can actually create experiences of so
many different sizes and scales and and
shapes and forms it actually opens the
door wide open so I know people who
might just take you know 10 clients at a
hundred thousand dollars a year and I'm
just giving you an example I'm not
saying this is going to be the way that
you start and they got a million dollar
business and then they I know people and
have clients who just have like a 197
offer and they also have a million
dollar business so there's actually so
many different ways to kind of slice or
dice that based on your strengths your
topic the goal that you've got and
that's something it's one of the reasons
why we actually everyone who studies
with us we give them a coach so you can
have these kinds of conversations versus
one size fits all answers where all
right we're gonna all create 197 course
and that's when your course becomes
undistinguishable and unrecognizable
from all the others brilliant well one
final topic as we land the plane in a
second is marketing lots of people
saying Harris Inkwell was saying I'm not
sure how to Market it what are the best
ways to Market it the cross Legacy
already has two courses but need the
next step of major marketing and of
course we will only be able to touch
that at a surface level because
marketing gets me excited especially
because YouTube Let me just add YouTube
would be a good you know uh success and
and that's of course why people are
subscribed to this podcast but whether
it's social media email marketing will
Circle back to that but I want to remind
everyone that I couldn't even get to all
these questions and I know you have many
more so if you want to be a part of the
challenge
um check out links in the show notes in
the description and then you can also
get the 20 most profitable online course
Mega niches for free that's a PDF
download at bestcourcetopics.com or
everything's in the show notes but let's
just cover this idea of marketing from
your standpoint we're recording this
towards the end of 2023 there's new
things there's tried and true things
what are maybe some of your uh big ideas
on marketing and then one or two tactics
that you personally like right now 100
so I think where people get challenged
is that marketing can come in so many
shapes and forms big and small and so
they think they've got to build this
like gigantic marketing machine just to
sell like one or two or ten copies of a
program or whatever it happens to be and
so I've got this idea of a circle of
influence right and so the one thing
that's really amazing when you're just
getting started is that you want to
start closer to the center of your
circle of influence friends and
Associates and friends of friends and
marketing is easier when you're actually
marketing to people who kind of are
familiar with you in one case or another
marketing only gets a lot harder when
you're going out to total strangers so
even if you have very little people in
your following and it's just people that
you know there's still going to be
people within that segment of people you
know and the people they know that needs
what you have to offer and so simply
getting consistent about posting on your
profiles whether you're a Facebook
person or an Instagram person or a
YouTube person you're going to start
getting in front of some people and then
you can also leverage other people's
audiences like here I am on your podcast
and while you might not be ready to have
absolutely everybody on your podcast
there's a lot of more beginner
podcasters who are just getting started
too so you can take advantage of their
audiences there's also blogs and sites
where they're always looking for Content
so there's ways to get in front of
people whether you just use your
existing kind of circle of influence or
whether you borrow other people's circle
of influence and you can kind of start
small and I think a lot of people like
oh my gosh I've got to be on every
platform posting every single day and
that quickly becomes overwhelming I just
taught my audience how to create an
authentic voice post on social on
Facebook LinkedIn or Instagram and just
doing that once a week all you're doing
is sharing something real and authentic
and I even gave them an authentic voice
post generated to create 14 different
types of types of authentic voice posts
and simply doing that those are the
longer posts that kind of share a story
or a moment or a brag that people tend
to really respond to so even if you
start that way posting once a week on a
single platform then you can add later
on all these other layers of tips and
quotes and content marketing I think
what the challenge people have is they
want to build this like Lamborghini and
they're trying to drive it to the
grocery store you know so if you're
minimum viable course is like going to
the grocery store you only need like
like a little kind of skateboard or
something you know what I'm saying and
so start small and just do something and
if you can start with doing something
consistently it's going to turn into
something bigger and bigger and bigger
and then you're going to have that
Lamborghini that you can kind of use to
sell thousand copies of your course but
that's not where most people start most
people see someone like you Sean with
this huge following or someone with me
like me with a huge audience too and
they think that we just somehow started
this way but they don't realize that we
started with these little tiny steps as
well and that's where everybody starts
and most people feel like they have to
take the giant leaps and by trying to
take the giant leaps they get
overwhelmed versus just taking the small
steps so good and I just want to clarify
one point and my understanding correctly
when you say you're helping people do
authentic voice posts mean meaning
you're helping them write in their
authentic voice and I know when I log
into Facebook long form text posts
either text only or perhaps with a photo
can just Crush when it's a story it's
about
pain they've been through a victory
they've had and that's what is that what
you meant by authentic voice yeah yeah
so I actually created this you know
identified 14 types of authentic voice
posts and my students had an authentic
voice post generator that I gave them
they just chose the type they said this
is the the tone of my voice and they had
eight options and then here are some
moments I want to include here's the
close and um and then it would just
generate a post and I said just post one
of these once a week over on your social
for example and that alone will start to
get you moving forward now even without
all of those tools even if you just
write one long form post like that and
you can use chat GPT as an assist and
you post that once a week on one
platform and you tie it into something
related to what you do then all of a
sudden it can get going you know I was
actually even demonstrating that if you
want me to to show you one of these
um I just demonstrated it live with my
student and created this post in like
you know less than five minutes flat I
all right and
um yeah so it is let me see chat EBT
were you using I had built a tool I
built a lot of tools for my students so
they generate content for them that are
leveraging AI but this particular
um one yeah was leveraging that you
could still do something really similar
inside of just chat GPT yourself but I
just wanted to show you know if you in
case you're interested in seeing this
yeah I mean you you can present your
screen here in screen yard yeah yeah let
me go ahead and do this so I just did
this in five minutes and so people think
it's like really hard but you can
actually
um sorry I'm looking for present my
screen okay uh share screen
let's do it uh here we go
so yeah this is one that I just did as a
demo to my students and
um you know it got uh some good feedback
and things here just this was a concert
that I went to in Italy I'll never
forget the day when my husband Murray
and I immersed ourselves in the soul
stirring rhythms of the Umbria Jazz Fest
10 days of music but two performances
etched themselves into my memory for
very different reasons Nika the pop star
and Mark Robo the legendary guitarist
Mika with his vibrant wardrobe changes
and grand piano turned interactive set
piece had a swing to his tombs even
though pop isn't my go-to genre he
understood that it wasn't just about the
music it was about the connection the
shared experience on the flip side Mark
rebeau lost in his virtuosity seemed to
forget about his audience his fear of
boring us ironically led to just that a
disengaged crowd that's when it hit me
it doesn't matter how intelligent or
talented you are or how good your online
course is if you can't engage people
you've lost them it's not about the
content it's about the experience
just like the music industry has evolved
from album sales to show tickets the
online course Market is Shifting towards
cohorts and experiences as an
entrepreneur specializing in online
course creation this Revelation was a
game changer to all my fellow coaches
consultants and course creators out
there let's not merely impart knowledge
let's create experiences that Captivate
engage and resonate because in the end
it's not just about what we teach it's
about how we make people feel so you
know it got great engagement there and
it took about five minutes so just
wanted to show you that you can do some
things that are really simple just to
start this process of engaging people
around you and around your course topic
right you could see it was all tied into
my course topic too yeah and that was a
mini master class on storytelling
um social sharing in such a way that it
wasn't just a a picture of your course
for sale that looked from graphic design
that said go buy my course it wasn't
even at that level of the journey too it
was pure engagement value adding
storytelling from your life turning one
of your life experiences into a bridge
to a revelation an idea and aha moment
into what it is and how you serve people
so obviously people have so much they
can learn from you and that's that's
really cool and I'm sure there's a lot
of interest in your tools
um as well because in today's world the
demands you know uh are ever increasing
whether it's all these different
platforms but the cool thing about AI is
it can bring some Harmony back now our
our philosophy too is not just so that
we can become these endless workhorses
but at ultimately that we can make great
content great products serve people buy
our time back with these tools like Ai
and uh then ultimately have more time
for what matters most to us like our
family and our purpose and and health
and a sustainable pace and so there's so
much more we could cover and you're
going to be covering that whether people
can join you on a live challenge or they
can download the PDF we'll link all that
in the show notes but how can people
also follow you and connect with you uh
anywhere else where's your favorite
place all right so we have an online
course creators community on Facebook so
if you search online course creators
Community it's been around since 2011 so
it's the oldest one a lot of people have
actually created look-alike groups based
on mine but it'll say since 2011 that's
the original one also follow me live
your message on YouTube leave your
message on Instagram
you can find me pretty much everywhere
Marissa I appreciate you so excited for
your upcoming Challenge and so excited
for all the value that our team has got
from you as well fake media podcast
definitely check out a summary of all
the show notes and uh go create your
online course serve people turn it into
an experience and we'll see you in a
future episode